i just want to say thank you a quick
thank you to everybody who has bought a
ticket to come and see the dire ceo live
show
anywhere in the uk i can't believe i'm
saying this but we launched a second
night at the london palladium
and it's sold out almost straight away
so we're going to do two nights in
february at the london palladium the
dire ceo live is just a
very unique musical
moving
personal development-centric empowering
experience for two hours in london in
glasgow in birmingham and in newcastle
taking place next year at the start of
the year i would love for you to come
i'd love to see you there
the show is completely sold out
everywhere but glasgow in newcastle we
have tickets on sale now
so if you're listening to this and you
trust me when i say it's something worth
coming to
the link is in the description below if
you're in glasgow or you're in newcastle
there are still a few tickets available
now i hope to see you there i'm the
creative director of pretty little thing
like i'm not just an influencer anymore
this is just the start for me i'm only
22 i've got so much more to learn we
literally only are given one life we
have to just go to the extremes i've
worked my absolute ass off to get where
i am now a lot of people don't believe
that but i work i spend time with my
boyfriend and i go to bed that is
actually my life i can't have anybody
knowing where i live i actually have
close protection security now and really
there's no price on feeling safe that
was like a really really low moment for
me when we got back it just felt cold
and eerie and it just didn't feel like
home anymore
he could literally go away for weeks on
end and there's not a doubt in my mind
that if he was to be around a load of
girls i could sleep peacefully at night
knowing that he's just he's for me and
i'm for him and that is literally the
key you've got trust you've got
everything there's so much more to it
than people see they have no idea what
really goes on i mean i would never say
like i've had like a mental breakdown
but that was close to it because i just
went crazy
[Music]
molly may
she is
in my opinion and according to a lot of
the data
the uk's number one
instagram influencer creator right now
she started out many years ago on a show
called love island but many people have
been on love island and nobody ever has
had the meteoric rise in their brand
their career their profile
like molly has
so as much as it's easy to say well okay
you know she had a boost from love
island that does not explain what's
happened in her life subsequently so i
wanted to sit down with her today and
find out exactly what's driving her
what's caused this meteoric success
almost 10 million followers in no time
at all
25 000 new followers a day
just imagine for a second being thrust
to the number one spot in terms of
influence and having tens of millions of
followers online
becoming a multi-millionaire overnight
and being
22
years old
imagine imagine the mistakes you would
make
it's absolutely fascinating and the way
she deals with it i think you'll find
incredibly inspiring
and what comes with that success
recently her house was burgled and she
reportedly lost 800 000 pounds worth of
her possessions and had to move
immediately to a new home she now has to
have 24 7 close protection security and
i'll be honest with you this is
something molly and her manager and team
shared with me before we started
recording molly doesn't do interviews
like this so this really is in many
respects her first real in-depth
interview of this kind
and i can't wait for you to hear it so
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
kitchen
that's where you're you grew up right um
take me back to hitchhiking what was
life like when you were growing up there
hitching i i actually still am extremely
fond of hitching and it was a really
it's a really really special place for
me i spent 18 years there growing up in
a very normal house with a very normal
family doing very normal things in a
very normal school
not private school anything it was just
an extremely normal um
yeah area to live in i loved it and
i got my first job there i i had a lot
of firsts there and i think it will
always hold a special place in my heart
i was a lifeguard there at a swimming
pool for four years
i had a job in hairdressers i worked in
a gym
it was all going on in hitch and that's
where it all began obviously is the air
family dynamics brothers sisters mum dad
tell me about your your family what they
do who they are what their character so
i have one sister she's actually in the
army she's three years older than me
people are always shocked when i say i
have a sister that's in the army because
obviously it's so
so different to what i do um but i'm
actually really proud of that i think
it's it's um i never really say that but
i'm super proud that she she is who she
is and we've grown up to be such such
different people but
both parents were in the police so that
was interesting growing up something
else that i'm really proud of actually
having two parents at police offices
because
i don't know i quite liked it at school
like sort of being known as the police
officer's kid like i kind of liked it no
one really messed with me
it was quite yeah like even at parties
like i think even a couple of times my
dad actually when i remember one time my
dad actually showed up to shut a party
down that i was at um yeah
yeah it was um that kind of thing having
um parents as police officers but i
didn't mind it
and at that age when you're in
hitchhiking what is it that you you want
to be when you grow up
oh god i mean
i i always wanted to be doing something
different i mean i went to fashion
school um
for two years because i really wanted to
pursue a career in fashion um all my
friends sort of stayed on and went to
sixth form and college but i again i
wanted to do something different i
wanted to do something outside the box
so i had an interview at the fashion
retail academy in london and i
got got a spot there and i ended up
going there for two years and studying
there i was commuting to london every
day at like 17 um so yeah it was outside
my comfort zone but i'm i'm really glad
i did that because it was just different
i loved doing things that were different
and did you did you have a because when
i was younger i wanted to be a dentist
and then a doctor and then yeah at one
point and then you know i bounced around
and then i was like i want to manage
your business yeah what were you saying
to yourself in terms of what you would
be when you were older did you have was
it fashion um i think when i was younger
it was mainly performing arts i've
definitely got that performing arts
streak in me i think a lot of people
that sort of fall into being in the
public eye do have a bit like that
performing art streak in them because
they have that confidence but i couldn't
quite make it in that i tried auditions
i tried you know castings all this but i
didn't quite have that i wasn't quite
there and i sort of accepted that very
quickly and realized to do well in
performing arts you have to be
the best it's like the most cutthroat
industry people say fashion's cut throat
no performing arts is like it's not
an industry you mess around in so i
accepted quite quickly that that wasn't
gonna work for me so fashion was was
where i focused on and i really did
think that i was gonna end up being like
a fashion buyer like a large business or
that's that's kind of what i wanted to
do
your your mum and dad lived very um as
police officers very uh solid yeah
lives and careers right yeah um did you
at that young age did you because i'm
trying to understand from like a very
young young age and i always ask this
about myself like how much of it was
this kind of in innate desire to have
more and be different and not live the
standard life yeah or how much of it is
just you know following following the
heart and seeing where it goes i think
for me watching my parents to have a
very ordinary life it sort of petrified
me a bit it was like
a bit terrifying this thought of
i don't want to grow up in this house
and and when i i'm old in my rocking
chair like tell my grandkids you know
like i had this really ordinary life and
i had an ordinary job i had an ordinary
income like that it petrified me from i
think around i reckon i started feeling
that way from about 15 i realized like
the world is literally our oyster and we
can do whatever we want with the 24
hours in the day that we're given so why
the hell am i not going to go out and
like make the most of them and do crazy
things and
make them like i said make the most of
it so yeah i think
my parents having this very ordinary job
like i mean police officers it's not
necessarily that ordinary but for me it
was like it just terrified me i was like
i don't want to have this life in
hitchen forever i know that there's so
much more to achieve and i moved to
manchester um when i was 18
and
started my life there i just moved out i
literally said to my mom one day i
walked down into the living room and
i'll never forget it and i said i found
this flat on right move and i'm moving
to manchester and she was like no you
know i was like no no i'm going she was
like you don't have enough money i was
like i'll find it like i'll make this
work and i literally went within a week
and i was gone i packed all my stuff up
and i just left and i moved to
manchester
and i remember the first night in my
apartment in manchester in ancoats i was
like oh what have i done i was like this
was the worst move i felt so homesick it
was horrendous but then i settled in and
it was the best thing i ever did looking
back on it now
were you moving for a job or you were
moving just because i did sort of um at
that point i sort of missed out i sort
of started to grow following on
instagram and it was growing quite
rapidly um and i'd found um a management
in manchester so i just thought i'm just
gonna go up there and just see what
happens like what's the worst that can
happen and all sort of the fast fashion
companies and everything was in
manchester at that point it became like
the new place to be
and so i just thought let's go let's do
it and yeah i went by myself no one
believed that i was going to do it and i
just did and yeah i definitely couldn't
afford my rent my mom was right i think
if
i'd stayed there any longer i probably
would have had to move back home at some
point because i really couldn't afford
my rent i think it was like 900 pounds a
month and i was barely making a thousand
pounds a month so after my rent i had
about 100 pounds to live on and a
starbucks at that point is what five
pounds so
um but yeah no it was the best thing i
ever did still in manchester now and i
don't plan on leaving i love it do you
consider yourself to be just thinking
about that taking that step because you
can often see in people's journeys
there's that like one step into
uncertainty where people think well i
don't know why she did that or i
wouldn't have done that myself but your
career seems to be riddled with these
kind of steps into uncertainty would you
consider yourself to be at that age
especially a confident person yeah i've
always been extremely confident i've
never ever struggled with um my
confidence like even meeting new people
trying new things like i've never
i've never i've never felt unconfident
in any situation which i'm really
blessed to have that like even you know
when i went on love island like going to
my auditions super confident always
super confident in everything i do
everything i i stand by like i just have
that confidence and i'm lucky to have
that because i think it's something that
just comes you don't you can't really
build on it like it's either there or
it's not um so yeah very confident
person do you think you're as you kind
of like so if we zoom forward a little
bit we'll zoom back but as you zoom
forward on this point of confidence um
one of the things i learned in my life
is as i managed to do more things and
achieve more things i actually realized
that the previous version of myself um
knew so little about the nature of the
world and i just want to like scream
back at myself oh my god steve even
though you were ambitious then yeah then
you were wrong like yeah you can do even
more
yeah as you as you look back on that
that you know that young girl in hitchen
yeah um and other people who will be in
that situation i'm saying i'm from a
small town where there's not a lot of
you know yeah global dreaming no
definitely not um what have you learned
about the nature of like confidence and
how it builds and how you're how capable
and how you know powerful your potential
really is as you've
climbed the ladder i think it's just
believing in
in that
beyonce has the same 24 hours in a day
that that we do and i just think like
it's literally you're given one life and
it's down to you what you do with it
like you can literally go in any
direction and when i've spoken about
that before in the past i have been
slammed a little bit with people saying
you know like it's easy for you to say
that you know you've grown up and you've
not grown up in poverty you've not grown
up you know with major money struggles
so if you to sit there and say that we
all have the same 24 hours in a day it's
not correct and i'm like but technically
what i'm saying is correct we we do so i
understand that obviously we all have
different backgrounds and we're all
raised in different ways and we do have
different financial situations but i
think if you want something enough you
can achieve it and it just depends to
what length you want to go to get where
you want to be in the future and i'll go
to any length like i i've worked my
absolute ass off to get where i am now a
lot of people don't think that and
believe that but
it's true i've worked so so hard
on that point of time and beyonce yeah
because of that that kind of mindset of
being very very um efficient with how
you spend your time
you must get a million requests to do
everything like i get a lot of requests
you must be getting pulled pushed do
this do that
how do you
make the decision as to what is truly in
line with who you are and where you want
to go when
you know like i don't think people
understand thousands you're probably
getting thousands of requests dms
opportunities some of them which i'm
sure you love to do yeah as you say 24
hours in the day yeah how are you
filtering that i think
what you've just said is actually the
key to why i've become successful in
what i do is because it is so strict
with what i do take on and what i don't
take on my days are planned out to like
the nth degree like it is so particular
what work i'm doing and everything is
done with such thought and like such um
understanding behind it like i'm never
taking on work that i don't understand
or
posting things on my socials that i'm
not 100 behind or using like i think
that is the key to being successful in
in this industry an influence thing if
you want to call it like it's it's
knowing what you're doing and knowing
what you're talking about is
is gospel like you use those products
you you stand behind what you're saying
like i think that is why i've i have
done well in what i and what i do
because i am so believing in what i say
and my followers know that like they
they know that i'm not talking about
something on my youtube unless i use it
unless i i believe in it and that is the
key to being successful in this you have
to have the trust of your audience so
what work we take on is it's honestly
one percent of what comes in less
probably
frank gets i'm not even joking 800
emails a day for work coming in it's it
never stops she's on our emails from 500
from 5 a.m i'm going through work that
comes in and it's
you have to turn down so much to or to
earn that respect from your audience and
that trust and between you and your
manager fran do you then have to kind of
initially agree
where you want to go with your career
what your values are what aligns with
you yeah and that kind of becomes the
filter of these 800 messages a day is
that the
we set goals we we have like fran and i
have like this sort of regular meeting
every like six months or so and we we
sit down and we we make a list of what i
want to achieve and it used to be well
at the start we were like going to do it
every year but i'm i am achieving them
rapidly now so we're doing it like every
few months and creating new goals and
setting new new targets of like okay i
want to work with this brand so if
they've not reached to me fram will
reach out and lo and behold it normally
happens where we we're a really really
great team and i think having a manager
that understands what your direction and
what you want to do is utterly key
because
you know
it's just so important like you can't do
it alone it's impossible like okay it's
not impossible but it's i couldn't do it
alone no way so um having a manager that
really really understands where you want
to go is just so so so important i think
and there's a there's a pretty
remarkable long-termism to your mindset
that i
i've garnered from watching some of the
videos that you'd made one in particular
was
the video where you know brand has come
along and offered you two million quid
to
like be the face of their brand or do a
relationship with them yeah and fran has
presented you with that opportunity yeah
and you said no i don't want to do that
yeah two million quid molly yeah i know
i would like dresses
if that brand is still looking for a
face
oh my god why did you say
that's the thing like as i just said
before like no amount of money can make
me take a job that i don't believe in if
i'm not wearing the clothes i'm not
taking the job no matter if they offered
me five million ten million and i just
solely believe that because the money
will come from your audience
like appreciate that you didn't take
that job and if do you know what i'm
saying like is i'd rather build that
trust than than take that money because
the trustees will earn you money in the
future anyway so i know that two million
is going to come back to me at some
point because i work with another brand
that i do believe in instead and my
audience will see that and they'll buy
into it they'll like the picture they'll
engage with the content whereas they're
not going to if i took that that brand
deal before so because the audience see
through they're not stupid like people i
follow on instagram that i love when
they do something that's not authentic i
see straight through it because you're
the consumer like you know and it's just
um yeah i think
i did i knew you'd bring out like two
million one because everyone was really
fascinated by it i think everyone was
really shocked but that's the society
that people don't see and i was really
glad that me and fran had that chat on
my youtube because it showed people that
you know it there's so much more to it
than people see that with this whole
influencing thing it's they have no idea
what really goes on
and my last point on this at this point
of you and fran one of the things i
found actually quite
quite remarkable
is um
when when you were coming down today and
you know we were sorting out the
logistics and those things you and
france did in the same hotel room yeah
which is not typical of you know manager
and client yeah how close are you you
and friends we're literally like best
friends she's i say like she's like a
second mom to me like it
it's grown that way because we spend
like we spend every day together we're
on the phone 24 7. like i speak to him
when i speak to tommy absolutely like
it's the constant constant conversation
it never stops if we're not on the phone
we're texting if we're not texting we're
in person with each other um
yeah so
like even after the last few weeks
what's been going on tommy and i like
fran took us in she's looked after us
it's she's like my mom in manchester
like without her i honestly don't know
how i'd have got through the last few
years of my life like she's
she's um yeah it's much more than a
manager and i'm so blessed i know it's
not a normal situation for people to
have a manager like that and i know
when you come out show that love island
having that manager that is on it is so
key it is honestly so so key because
without that it can really really fluff
things up for you which i've seen first
hand with so many people and it's so sad
but yeah so let's talk about that then
so love island um i don't want to talk
too much about it because i think
everybody understands the show and the
concept of it but when you first were
presented with the opportunity and
you're debating because a lot you know i
think everyone's got a mate who says oh
yeah love island asked me to be on it
and i said no that nonsense right when
you first were presented with the
opportunity
what was your incentive for saying yes
well
it's tricky i've always struggled with
how to talk about it because i answered
a question once on my youtube about was
love island a business move for you like
and i and it is tricky for me to say the
right thing without upsetting people but
put it this way i didn't go on that show
to find love no one does people go on it
for the experience people go on there
for a laugh and i think because i went
on there with a completely probably
incorrect mindset that's why i did come
out with a boyfriend and i think because
you know when you're not expecting
something it happens um but yeah i
remember that it they came forward and i
just thought
at the time my influencing was going
really well and there was actually a
side of me that thought i can actually
do this without going on this show like
i know i'll be finding the way my
following my following was growing
rapidly like i think i was about 170 000
followers at that point and that was all
organic growth there was no tv shows or
anything and i hadn't had any friends of
large followings that's what i posted me
it was all very natural growth so i knew
i'd i'd say now that if i hadn't gone on
the show i'd probably be i'd like to be
hitting a million followers um because i
had that really good work ethic with my
instagram but
the show just sort of
it just elevated me and then i think one
thing i always say is that when you come
off that show you're all on a level
playing field and it's totally up to you
where you go with it and i just knew
that i wanted to go
just
to levels no one had ever gone to
and that's why i never really speak
about it because i just feel like i
don't owe it
that's not the reason why i am where i
am now yeah it gave me a platform yeah
it elevated me but the things i've done
now not because of love island they're
because of me and what i've decided to
do my work ethic
so i want to drill down on that point
then so you're completely right um love
island is a platform but
the it's super super clear that if you
look at the outcome of everybody that's
been on that platform
the results are wildly varying
and um you're you've
you know you're part of that platform
yeah but what's happened to you
subsequently
after you've been on that show yeah is
um
unprecedented there's not been another
example of someone who has risen so high
following being involved in that
platform so what is it about you
and
you know your character your you know
whatever it might be i don't put the
answer in your mouth what is it about
you that's that's caused that
so many different things but i think i
knew the minute i came off that show
that i just wanted to do crazy things
and one thing for me is that when i
reach one goal it's what can i achieve
next it's never enough for me and i
think it's a bit of a downside to my
personality because when i achieve
something incredible i i just want more
i always want more like i remember i was
speaking to round about this i was like
i remember when my goal was i really
want to get a million pounds my bank
account that's all i wanted to do i was
like that is my goal and then the minute
i reached it i was like well i want to
now i want two million and it's like i
never i'm happy with where i'm at i'm
constantly working towards the next
thing but i think you need that you need
that
work ethic you need that
desire to always want more it's never
enough for me even when i got my
biggest dream collabs and it's just what
can i get next fran think of it as well
she's like it's enough now come on
when someone hears that they might think
well how did how do you
how would you be happy and satisfied and
content
whilst always striving to have more and
more and more and once you get to that
mountaintop or what you thought was the
mountain top they call it like a false
peak and climbing where you get that bit
and then you look up and there's more to
go yeah and you can and so how do you
find the happiness amongst and amidst
the climb yeah i'm working on that i
think because
even recently that we moved in into a
new place we moved into this new house
and i've realized i've actually got a
bit of a problem with it because i was
like this house is literally a dream
it's a dream but it's not enough for me
because i still want more like i still
want a bigger house i still want bigger
things and it's like i need to work on
that because you do need to find that
happiness because you know 16 17 year
old me is screaming at the things i'm
doing right now and i'm still like it's
not enough you know but i think that's
why i i'm doing the things i'm doing and
i am achieving great things because it's
i'm never sort of like okay i'm happy
this week i'll just sit down and and
this is fine no it's like what are we
doing next week it's it's always more
why do you think you want more
what does it what emotionally
psychologically in the mind what what is
it that's
saying that more why is more important i
think again going back to that point
where like when i when i'm older and
i've got my kids around me and i want to
literally look back and say like my life
was unbelievable like i did
every single thing i could possibly ever
want to do there's not one thing on my
list that's not ticked and i think i'm
not there yet and i know i can achieve
more because
it's possible so why not like we
literally only are given one life we
have to just
go to the extremes and that's what i'm
trying to do
i am i'm very much the same in many ways
and over the years i think i got to a
point where my book is called happy sexy
millionaire because at 18 i wrote in my
diary range bear in mind i was living in
moscow and didn't have a driving licence
a ranger over sport would be my first
car make a million before i'm 25 i'll
have a girlfriend and i'll have a
six-pack basically right that's my life
goals
brilliant 24 i'm driving a range over
sport millionaire whatever whatever
whatever and then
that anti-climax of getting there yes
this like feeling of where's the
marching band in the confetti like i
thought it's a huge anti-climax isn't it
it's it's mental like don't get me wrong
it's incredible to reach your goals but
it is a little bit oh
you know when you hear people the
richest people in the world they say
you're not happy though because you have
all this money you think yeah you are
happy like cause you are you've got all
this money but they're probably not
because it really actually doesn't mean
anything all of that stuff your
happiness comes from within and the
people around you and your life it
doesn't come from how much money you
have in your bank and what car you drive
and what house you live in it really
doesn't it sounds cliche but i've
learned that and i'm only 22 in it and
i've realized that straight away i'm
like oh gosh okay it actually doesn't
come from all this stuff it comes from
your mental state and and your family
and that the more important stuff really
the non-superficial stuff
that anti-climax is very real then my my
concern as you said there is like i just
was scared that i'd never be happy if
i'm not happy now because yeah like this
is like i think for both of us from what
you said anyway this is the dream
that hitchin molly may yeah dreamed of
and you and hitch and molly mate 17 said
when we get there at 22 we're going to
be happy
i'll sit on my sofa and i won't work
another day and i'll be happy and i'll
just it's not that way it isn't you
think it will be and don't get me wrong
it's incredible and i'm so happy i'm the
happiest i've ever been i
don't want for more but i do if that
makes sense i don't know have you got a
lot of friends
no i don't that's that's a blunt
question yeah not there's lots of
questions
straight up no no i don't my circle is
minuscule i have literally about five
people in my circle and that includes
friends i have acquaintances and i have
people in my life that i i stay in my
friends by
no my circle was absolutely tiny and i
like it that way i wouldn't have it any
other way um
i work i spend time with my boyfriend
and i go to bed that is actually my life
and i'm not bothered about social life
it's never been something that i've been
interested in i don't know if you've
like i don't know if you know but i
don't really drink i don't party i don't
go out but that is just because i
actually don't enjoy it it's not for me
i'd rather just focus on making money
being successful and and being happy
that's
friends they come and go and i just i
find it always a better waste of time so
you don't you don't actively
want more friends no yeah no it's it's
time consuming like trying to make
people happy like
i've lost a lot of friends but since
coming off love island because i don't
have the time and i and in the end i
just say you know what look like
i'd rather focus on the things that are
actually going to elevate me and and it
sounds savage but
sometimes friends they just
not cling on but they they don't add
much
yeah and that sounds a bit savage but no
it's true and especially when you evolve
as a person you kind of sometimes i
think you lose the thing that made you
resonate with certain people yeah yeah
100
well i'm not that girl from hitchen
anymore and you know like i'm not that
young girl that was a lifeguard at hitch
in swimming pool like that's not me i
i've i'm living a completely different
in a different world now and a lot of my
friends can't relate to that and even
though i'm still the same person my life
and my circumstances are just so
different that you do just naturally
just people just fall off don't they but
friends have never i've never needed
lots of friends it's just something that
i've never really needed and people pick
up on pick up that about me really
quickly they just say like you've got
your circle so small
bit of a loner but i like it i you know
i asked that question in part because
every
successful person i've sat here with
doesn't have a lot of friends no and you
know i was actually having a
conversation with one of the previous
guests on this podcast and she's got two
and a half million followers on
instagram and she was telling me last
night that she has one friend as her
boyfriend yeah that's about right she
literally said i have one friend and
it's my boyfriend yeah that sounds that
sounds about right for me and it's
sometimes it's weird because when i ask
you this question it feels really
uncomfortable yeah when you first said i
was like oh god no i don't but it's yeah
it's it's a weird one because you don't
want to sound like you you don't have
any friends because then people think
you're probably the problem there do you
know me like you're pushing people away
but it isn't that it's just like i
haven't got the time like i really would
rather just spend time with fran because
we're friends and we talk about work and
we get we you know we we make money and
then i spend time with my with my
boyfriend because he's amazing and i
just you don't need to force the
conversation you'd have to go for
dinners and spit the bill it's just like
oh it sounds terrible but i just don't
have the time for it
i'm lazy with it has it become hard to
trust people
um especially following you know your
meteoric rise in the public eye does it
get more difficult to trust
yeah people did because there were you
know people always well sometimes people
are in it for themselves they're trying
to sell stuff up stories about you or
they're trying to take advantage of yeah
i've been quite blessed with my
rise in that i because my circle has
always been small i've not really had to
cut people off because they're you know
selling stories to the press i've never
had that i mean that i know of anyway um
i mean yeah but um
yeah i mean you you do have to be
worried about who's in your life because
i i think franwise says this to me she's
like you just think you're still that 17
year old girl from hitchens sometimes
you're not and people will come into
your life for the wrong reasons but i
think i'm a bit naive to that sometimes
and that is another reason why i keep my
circle so small because it's different
now i think that it's just it's hard to
it's hard to trust people
i am i was watching something you you
said about how you've been very open
about sharing the lows and the highs
that you come with
your meteoric rise and the publicity and
being in the public eye
it's very easy to see a lot of the clear
upsides all right
the nice things they're like general
sense of i'd say like freedom to choose
freedom of choice in your career and
stuff like that but what are some of the
like trade-offs of that success which
you just think oh that sucks
well there's a lot there's lots
obviously i've dealt with a lot in the
last two years in terms of i was trolled
extremely badly i mean it's like a
cliche topic and i and i don't really
talk about the trolling a lot because
it's i feel like it's all anyone talked
about on social media these days is
trolls and trolling and
but it it it did happen to me extremely
badly and there was this one time we
went to barbados to shoot a campaign for
my fake town business and um we were
followed the whole trip by paparazzi we
didn't even realize and they were posing
as like architecture um photographers in
front of this building and and i did
think at one point is that guy taking
pictures of me but i just thought no
he's taking pictures of the building
behind me there's no way in barbados
that they're gonna be taking pictures of
me anyway that afternoon
um
me stood in this white bikini like
completely like they were just the most
horrendous pictures in my eyes and i i
actually rang the daily mail myself i
went through to someone on customer
service and i just was like this is
molly mae you must take those pictures
down now like i was hysterically crying
and i was and this poor person on
customer service was probably just like
what is going on and i was just
screaming down the phone like please
like you've ruined my life like look at
the comments under that picture like
please take them down and it was just
like when i look back at that now i mean
i would never say like i've had like a
mental breakdown but that was close to
it because i just went crazy i was like
screaming down the phone this personal
customer service that couldn't do
anything about it but for me i was like
this is going to make it better like if
they take them down it will all go away
but that was like a really really low
moment for me um probably like the
lowest of coming out of the show it was
horrendous it was just horrendous like
people calling me fat um overweight and
i'm a size eight so like it just it made
me so upset to think that if people are
calling me overweight you know a girl a
very normal size 10 girl like what are
they going to be thinking if i'm being
called fat like it's it's heartbreaking
and i think
the whole trolling thing like i have
kind of dealt with it now like i'm
really good at dealing with it i thought
i've had this approach of like if
it doesn't matter like people can say
what they want to say these people are
just genuinely so unhappy in their lives
that they try and bring you down and
it's so sad but um you do learn to deal
with it it's just part of it and we've
really we've learned in terms of like
we're on always on pap watch now and if
we go away on campaigns like we
literally have someone that's job is
specifically to look out for people
taking pictures so it doesn't happen
again because it was it was quite bad
that for me those daily mail comments
really are a cesspool of just vileness i
remember when i was announced as a
dragon on dragon's den and like i don't
look at comment sections because i'm
just really not bothered it's like not
going to add to my life but then my
family calling me and being like oh my
god those comments my mom doesn't like
racist i'm like don't look at them
my mom does that to me she goes have you
seen the comments on the daily mail i'm
like mom why would you tell me that like
you don't look i'm not looking so
neither do you i just leave it but yeah
i think obviously they're just looking
out for you and they don't understand
that you're probably just trying to
avoid it that's a pretty remarkable way
to live is you're talking about you know
being on holiday and having someone on
pap watch and
you must always be on edge yeah you are
some degree you are always on that edge
and it's it's a weird way to live but
it's become normal now it's been two and
a half years and that was really early
on in barbados that was i think maybe
three months four months after i'd come
out the show and that was okay this is
how we need to live now this is how we
need to do things and it's just been the
same and having an incredible team as
well
to be protective of you is is i'm really
lucky for that because i couldn't do it
by myself it is you're really vulnerable
like it's such a vulnerable job to have
um
and yeah perhaps posing as architect
photographers like it's just
there's snakes everywhere yeah man
before we started recording fran your
manager told me that you are a little
bit of a perfectionist and that you care
a lot about getting all the details
right for your customers but across your
life generally so i guess my question to
you is how do you do that how do you
dare i say worry about details and also
still maintain your peace of mind
i mean it's it's
compartmentalizing it's sort of like i
i don't really switch off it's almost
like i just it's sort of built into my
mind it's a 24 7. it's i'm always always
thinking in back my mind how everything
i'm doing is affecting my work because
that's i am my job at the end of the day
like
i'm molly may and molly may make what
makes me my income it's not like i go to
work and i come back and i switch off
i'm 24 7 on my phone so everything i'm
doing everything i'm saying one story
post that takes two seconds to post
everything i do affects how i
make money how my audience perceives me
so it's i just think i've just sort of
like
i don't know it becomes one my life is
just is
it sounds chaotic right and it also
sounds like
i find it pretty remarkable based on
people i've spoken to that live in a
similar way that are very neurotic and
that are always one and always thinking
and then yeah are in the middle of the
like social media instant feedback
bubble yeah how would you avoid being
anxious and that's in within that
cauldron
you really just have to sort of
accept that instagram as instagram and
there's always going to be that one
person on instagram that that doesn't
like what you're doing i've got 6.2
million followers it is impossible to
please everybody so i've really had to
understand that you know everything i
say and everything i do not everyone's
going to like it no matter how much i
wish they did because it would put my
mind at rest a lot knowing that
everybody loves what i'm doing there's
always going to be that one person that
that hates what you're doing and hates
you so you just sort of have to
sort of understand that instagram is
just it's very superficial and it's just
a highlight real that's why i love my
youtube as well because i feel like my
youtube is so
behind the scenes it's
you really get that
that bigger picture you see the bad
stuff that's happening in my day and i
think do you know what i think not to
stand behind it but i think that is why
i have a really high engagement on my
instagram
it's because my followers they they see
me on youtube when they see that picture
on instagram and they think we know that
she's not actually had a good day we
know that she's actually
i spoke about a few months ago how i
wanted this really really incredible job
opportunity and i didn't get it and i'm
really transparent like i'm like today's
been crap i've cried today like i've
come my period today i'm feeling really
rubbish today like i'm i'm really really
transparent so i think when they see
that picture on instagram they know
actually if we want to see a bit more of
like a realist side here we'll just go
to our youtube and have a look and i
love that that is why i to all my
influencer friends i say start youtube
start youtube if you want your
engagement to grow if you want your
audience to fall in love with you if you
want people to understand you more you
have to start youtube because instagram
is
it's nothing it's a picture i post one
picture a day what's anyone going to
learn from that picture nothing
youtube is where it's at that's where
they learn that's where they engage with
you and understand you and believe in
you and that's the depth right yes
it's so important like i do youtube
because i love it i've i still edit all
my own content i still yeah i i'm
really i love it i actually find it um
therapeutic
editing my videos and i love um when i
finish editing a video and i upload it i
love that sense of i just created that
and it's bigger than just editing an
instagram picture and putting it through
color tone and putting a filter on it
you've spent time developing that video
and you've created and millions people
are going to go and watch that and spend
their 20 minutes of their day watching
that video that you've created and i
love that feeling that's really special
and i've had so many videos editors say
like oh i'll do and i would never give
that job to someone else one of the
things i find really fascinating is link
to what you said there about being very
honest and open with your audience but
at the same time again if we're talking
about things that feel
like
they don't marry together or they feel
like contradictions is
as you rise and rise and rise and as you
experience more like material success
and you can buy nicer things
do you become less relatable to your
audience and is this is this something
you think about because the girl you
know that is 16 right now living in
hitchens looking up at you and you're
getting you're getting apparently
further and further away from
being you know that's such an
interesting question even when you're
saying that then i was like that's a
really valid point and i actually don't
be wrong i'll be honest i do see
comments on my instagram saying like
you know can you do like a more high
street haul this week can you talk about
more high street clothes because don't
forget in that six million followers
there's such a wide
variety of people there's that 45 year
old mum that's
you know living on food stamps you know
and she's got no money and she wants to
see me post really normal things but
then i've got probably another girl
that's following me an 18 year old girl
that
dad funds their life and they want to
see the glamorous
there's it's such it's impossible to to
sort of cater for everyone i try and as
i thought as you say as i sort of
my life is changing so much i'd still
try and stay as relatable as possible
and i do i i would say that i am still
extremely relatable and again that's my
youtube i post yeah all these incredible
things that i borrow my instagram and
i've sort of stopped doing that now but
i i
well
oh because yeah fine yeah
but um i
i sort of that's again my youtubers i'm
i'm there's
in a vlog i might be saying oh i've just
bought this brand new watch it's amazing
it's cost x amount and i'm having a
really great day but then i also might
say oh you know i mean time i've just
had a huge argument and i've walked out
the house i there's it's
in a vlog i try and
keep that balance as much as possible so
i can sort of
not because i cater for everyone's just
because i am that way
life is like that way you know when
you're being honest one minute
something's really great next minute
something's really [ __ ] and that's just
the way it is and i guess there's
there's two forces there really because
i think if i was um well not even but if
i was following you it'd be for two
reasons right for me on one hand it's
aspiration it's oh my god look at this
amazing thing all these amazing things
she's achieved and i really aspire to be
there one day but then obviously the
relatability comes from the fact that
you're talking about how bad your period
pains are and this problem with your
boyfriend and those are things we can
all relate to yeah and then on the other
hand there's all these wonderful things
that we can all aspire to yes and i
think i think at the end of the day it's
interesting with social media because a
lot of people in your position wouldn't
share the aspirational things because
they'll
care too much about what people might
say yeah i would actually say the
opposite i would say i think a lot of
people share the aspirational things but
they don't share the low moments that's
true when i when i'm watching people's
youtubes i'm seeing so many girls being
like my life is just so amazing and i do
these amazing things and i'm a vegan and
i eat clean and i go to the gym and they
don't talk about the low moments and
they wonder why their audience isn't
engaged you have to be honest you have
to include those things that maybe you
don't really want to include it but your
audience will appreciate that because
that girl is probably also having a
crappy day that's watching it so she
wants to see you also having a crappy
day so she knows it's okay
and that's where i think some
influencers and some youtubers they they
fall down because they don't they're not
100 honest whereas i really really am
and i stand by that um yeah if you buy
something really expensive though let's
say you buy something really really
expensive when you go to post it is
there an is there a feeling of like
concern about
it might make some people feel
you know that struggling might make them
feel bad or inadequate in a way yeah i
mean it's tricky isn't it it's
it's hard to know what you're gonna what
you post how it's gonna affect people
like you might think the post in one
thing will have no effect on somebody
but actually it could be all that person
thinks about that day and it's kind of
scary it's a massive responsibility
because i have super young followers as
well and i've got to be careful you know
i've been on a bit of like a health
journey recently i've got to be so
careful talking about weight loss and
what i'm eating because you don't know
what you're saying it's so
impressionable and these young girls
they're so again vulnerable and i know
when i was watching girls instagram
stories i mean
i'm sure i'll talk to you about filler
in a bit but i instagram was the reason
i ended up getting all that filler
because i was watching these girls
stories thinking they have filler so i
need to go and get filler so if i'm
posting about you know a health journey
and i've lost a few pounds i feel great
well then young girls are going to go
and think well i need to go lose a few
pounds if molly may's done it so
everything you're saying it has to be so
clearly thought about because it's
you have no idea how that one tiny story
is going to affect that person's day
with everything isn't there a lot of
things though where you just can't you
can't there's no way to get it right you
can't control it no you can't get it
right all the time i feel like there
must be so many things where if you post
it you're gonna get back because this i
i experience it a little bit people it's
funny with with them with me i i and
i've learned this again from my guests
that i've sat here with i can get away
for some reason with a bike with a lot
more yeah they can so i can post
something and i'll typically get like
pretty much 100 pos like a good example
actually was when um
i'd been in the gym a lot and i'm saying
to grace who's in my content team i'm
like i'm gonna post a topless photo and
say like show my gym transformation
before and after and grace raises it to
me that like a lot of
influencers who do that gets like
slammed for you know what what you're
saying you're saying six packets yeah
yeah i'm like no one's gonna say that in
my audience i post it everyone's
clapping everyone's like amazing give us
your tips
but it seems to be like almost a double
standard
for women creators and women like you
if i look at it and think oh man you got
it's like a minefield of
correctness i know honestly but that is
another reason why i stay quiet on a lot
of things i don't i'm often fearful to
speak and even on twitter i kind of
stopped using my twitter because
everything you say like you i remember a
few months ago i went to italy for um a
trip and i mentioned that i'd i didn't
like the food in italy and the way i
worded it probably wasn't it i probably
could have worded it better but i was
trending on twitter for four days
about how i said i didn't like the food
in italy and and i was like literally
going through a really hard time i was
like i can't deal with this like i've
made one comment that people didn't like
about the ice cream in italy and i'm
literally trending and i'm getting like
death threats because of it and it's a
lot it's a lot like it's how i mean i
always say like when i don't have like a
scandal for a while i'm thinking god's
scandal's coming soon i'm going to say
something wrong soon like it is you're
kind of always on the edge of like
what's going to be next like what's
what's happening next
so
with all this you know when you say this
to me
my like i've got to be honest i don't
envy that situation because i think one
of the forms of
um one of the real causes in our society
and in the world of
mental health issues is feeling like you
can't be your true self yeah and
there are physical forms of imprisonment
putting someone in a jail and then there
are mental forms of imprisonment which
is like stopping them speaking freely
about who they are who they love what
they think and what they feel and
yet when in every interview that i've
encountered with you the answer i see is
i'm very very happy
um
how can how how is how is that all
possible for you to live in a world
where there is so much concern and so
many minds that you could possibly step
on
and to still be
happier i know
i am always saying that i'm happy
because how i i think it'd be selfish
for me to say that i'm not like how
could i not be happy like
17 year old me creates backup things i'm
thinking like god
i am happy because this is all i ever
wanted and yes every day in my mind i
think god i've i have got these worries
and i have got these struggles but let's
just take a step back i am happy like i
i sort of have to just
look at the bigger picture i'm healthy i
have my health my family's well i have
an incredible manager i have an
incredible boyfriend i live in a
beautiful house i'm safe i'm happy like
i am yeah i've got all these these
worries about when am i next gonna have
a scandal when am i gonna say the wrong
thing and
but in the bigger picture like 17 year
old me again could only dream of this
[ __ ] and i'm living it so that's how i
look at it
and that gratitude you know it's clearly
so important to be
yeah centered and grounded amongst all
of this chaos right yes yeah 100 i i am
very grounded and i think that's one
thing that i'm proud of is that everyone
that knows me from my life prior to love
island they've all said i've never
changed i've always stayed the same
yeah my life my circumstances have
changed but me myself i'm the same
person and i and i know i am i've never
become
bougie i've never become like i've never
you know i just i couldn't it's not me i
am that i am still that girl from
hertfordshire but just with a very
different life now but i've never
changed even then since i've met fran in
that two and a half years i'm still the
same person that she met on that day
when i came out of love island so yeah i
stand by that and i'm proud that i've
stayed the same
what are these drinks here
so this is huel
um
it's basically nutritionally complete
food so it's um it's the fastest growing
ecommerce company in the country oh
isn't it yeah online internationally
it's basically like it's like your your
perfect meal
in a drink so 20 you know all your
proteins all your vitamins all your
minerals vegan gluten free and if you're
ever on the i'm sure you are because
you're super busy if you're ever on the
go and you're like skipping meals and
stuff yeah you have one of these fills
you and make sure that you get all
everything you need amazing so i think
as the world has got busier
he always got more
popular you know but anyway right i have
to try hill yeah we'll give you thank
you
they actually send you a big package
after this they always do it so okay um
not that anyone knows where you live now
you know where i live
i'll send it to france
speaking about social media and you know
one of the changes you made and you've
talked about this publicly is you
removed the cosmetic filler from your
face
right yeah and um
and other things other sort of changes
to your sort of cosmetic appearance can
you talk to me first about what it was
that made you want to go and get
cosmetic filler in your face
well
i think
i'm really very beautiful oh thank you
well i was 7 16 or 17 when i first got
filler and 16 if it was i think is
actually illegal
um i think you have to be 17 legally um
but i i went and got lip filler when i
was around 16 and
it didn't stop for a few years i kept
getting it and i kept getting it and it
became around that time was when it had
become very normalized filler was it was
literally like going to go into the gym
like i'm just going to get a top of my
lip filler it became so normalized which
is terrifying and so scary that
these things are spoken about on social
media like these these um aesthetic
pages they're posting all these packages
you can get with filler and it's it
became really normal so i just i went
one day and i just got it and it was
like nothing and i didn't tell my mom i
just kept it from everyone no one even
really noticed but i think on social
media as i said before i was seeing all
these girls
um
with filler and with all these things
onto my face their faces so i thought
well if i want to be successful in that
industry if i want to be an influencer
and i want to have a large following i'm
going to have to get that too like i'm
gonna need to do that to my face i need
jaw fuller and cheek filler and lip
filler and botox to look the way these
girls do
um when actually when i realize now is
all just editing none of them looked
like that anyway
but um it's scary because it i i
wouldn't say i got addicted to it but
uh by the age of 21
i didn't look like the same person i
literally looked like a different person
it was when i look back at pictures now
i'm i'm terrified of myself i'm like who
was that girl i don't know what happened
and it was actually only until my sister
said to me and she was like we need to
sort this out it was i took her to tell
me i was a um a pa in in a club i don't
know where i was and she texted me and
she was like i need to talk to you about
the filler like it's too much now like
it's it's it's enough you need to stop
and then i actually sort of i remember
going on my front camera and i was
looking i was like what are you talking
about and i actually realized i was like
i don't it's not nice this it's
my face and literally everyone used to
call me quagmire i don't even know
quagmire is i think it's like a cartoon
character i don't know oh okay well
people would either say on the screen
yeah quagmire people used to say
quagmire or they said i looked like an
xbox controller like my face was that
warped like i got all
kinds of things um but there was this
one pivotal moment where i'd gone and
i'd got loads of filler and i posted a
youtube video um
and i hadn't let the filler sort of
settle and it was really swollen and a
picture from a screenshot from that
video it trended on twitter
for weeks it was horrendous it was
utterly horrendous it was like you can
insert the picture we'll send it to you
it was
my face was literally like it was just
awful and it was that was a moment for
me as well where i was like i think i
think things need to change i i thought
one day i'm actually i'm gonna get my
lips dissolved in it and it it was a
process i went and got my lips dissolved
and i posted about it on youtube and i
didn't expect the response that i got it
was huge and a lot of girls were
tweeting they made me laugh and was like
molly making lip filler does not mean
that we will have to get her little
dissolved story does not mean that we
will have to go and do the same because
obviously they all love their lip filler
which i think is great like some girls
absolutely love it and by me getting my
filler dissolved did not mean that i i
don't agree with philip i got it at one
point like i i obviously loved it and
some girls it makes them feel super
confident and it did for me for a while
until i took it too far i think it can
be a great thing it's not for me to sit
here and bash it because some girls
they do feel amazing with it and that's
that's great but for me um
the minute i started to sort of reverse
my image and dissolve the filler and
dissolve my lips and i actually had full
set of composite um bonding like veneers
on my teeth i had them removed as well
i literally took it to the extremes and
i just stripped myself back and weirdly
i felt the prettiest i'd ever felt once
it had all gone and i i feel like i'd
dropped about five years off my age and
it was like it was a really really
significant moment for me and i just
stripping everything back and
i didn't realize how much respect that
would get me i didn't do it for respect
i did it for myself i didn't do it for
anyone else i did it because i knew that
i needed to but from doing it
all these young girls were like well all
these young girls parents were emailing
fran and saying thank you so much like
this is so amazing for us to see it's so
different i actually had some a mum come
up to me when i was visiting hitchhiking
with my mum she came up to me in the
street crying her eyes out saying that
she was so grateful to me for doing what
i did with my filler because she's so
happy that like the effect it had on her
children and my mom started crying and
it was all like emotions my mum was she
when the woman walked away she's like
i'm so proud of you and i just didn't
realize like from me doing that the
effect it would have on so many people
your manager fran told me she said um
when you made that decision to remove
the cosmetic filler and the the bonding
from your teeth um she was getting so
many emails she couldn't keep up with
her inbox from parents saying expressing
their admiration and gratitude because
obviously previously um those parents
and their children had been looking up
to certain role models who do do a lot
of editing because of you know because
of the comparison-based world we live in
and to have a role model like yourself
who has taken the very very brave and
um i braves maybe not the right word but
just a very
important step to say that i'm gonna be
a role model that doesn't um
tamper too much with my face because of
the consequences and what that might
tell my audience about themselves
when you went on your transition when
you went from being you know a little
bit too much filler here maybe in bonded
teeth and stuff like that to the oh
natural molly that you are now was there
other moments of doubt where you looked
at yourself and thought you know what
maybe i'll knit back in yeah well yeah i
mean it didn't happen overnight i can't
sit here and say like i suddenly just
felt incredible like it was a huge
change like i literally i looked like a
different person with all the filler in
a different person with it out
and um
there was a moment where i'd i'd just
done the cover for cosmopolitan magazine
and it was a really big deal to me i was
so
hugely happy that i'd landed the cover
because
um i it was a dream it's huge my mom
used to buy me that magazine when i was
younger and it was it was i couldn't
believe that i was gonna be on the cover
but that was the first time i'd been
pictured after i'd had all the filler
removed and i actually despised the
picture so much that i just i cried
about it for days yeah because i didn't
get approval of the image and i just
thought i sort of prayed i was like i
really hope i like the image and i i
absolutely hated it and it went
it went out and it was fine and everyone
was telling me how amazing i looked and
it was kind of sad that after everyone
sort of confirmed that they they thought
i looked nice then i felt better that's
a bit sad because i think i didn't until
i've until people started to start to
say that and i never really thought i
was that girl i always sort of thought i
don't need people to tell me that i
looked nice like it
but i think then i did because i was
really vulnerable like i just had all
this filler removed no one had really
seen me like that i looked really
different i did and i think people
noticed it but people really admired it
because it was different it was new no
one had no one had really done that yet
i wouldn't want to say that i started a
trend but i do feel like i did start a
bit of a trend with the sort of
dissolving and again i'm proud of that
because yeah i might have been a bit
uneasy about it at first but now loads
of people are doing it and i love it
it's like an amazing movement
and with the with the brands that you're
involved in in the businesses you run do
you now seek out models and influencers
and creators that are representing
that more natural look as well i
wouldn't even say so because as i said
before i don't think phil is a bad thing
if it's done safely and it's done in a
way that makes a girl feel more or a guy
feel more confident then then that's
great whatever makes that person feel
amazing that's what i like and if a
model comes in and we like her and she's
got a face full of filler that's not a
problem because another girl that's
looking at that campaign also might have
a facebook affiliate you know again it's
i don't really judge people based on
things like that i made a mistake with
it once and but at one point i loved it
and it did make me feel confident so no
i think we just
like when we look booking models for
filtering things we just want to be
relatable and we want to
sort of
have a girl modelling up the fake hand
that that
lots of girls can relate to that's why
we use always use multiple models in our
campaigns and plus size and
we we
try and sort of cater to everybody
imposter syndrome when people rise very
very quickly into high places
they often talk about this feeling of
imposter syndrome where they
you know
inside them maybe they're still that
girl from hitching but they're in these
like big rooms with these big things
talking about big ideas and do you ever
feel that
um
i i guess i'm
i'm extremely honest when i need
to ask questions when i don't understand
what the hell is going on like i
actually said to fran i was like i bet
stephen's gonna use loads of words that
i have no idea what they mean and i just
have to sit here and pretend that i have
a clue what he's on about when really i
don't does that happen yet no
but when i was listening to your one
with patricia bright you said a few
words and i was like don't know what
that means i was like he's definitely
that's gonna happen but i'm really
honest
i'm really transparent when i'll be in
finance meetings with fran and we'll be
talking about gross profit and i say can
we just rewind i have no idea what we're
talking about here and i'm really really
transparent with that like i tried to
just remember i am 22 they didn't teach
me this stuff in school they they really
didn't and i i'm talking about mortgages
and stuff i didn't know what a mortgage
was until a few months ago i'll be
honest because when i started looking at
buying a house i said what is a mortgage
because i didn't know and i think um
that's how i've gotten away from that
like imposter syndrome i just i
i just ask i just ask the questions i'm
not embarrassed and um i've had to learn
a lot really quickly i didn't know
anything at the start this process i
didn't know i don't think i hadn't had
enough money to even pay a tax bill
before i didn't understand i was making
a thousand pound a month before the show
so i'd never paid a tax bill like it and
it was
it was a lot of learning very quickly
and i've just always asked i'm not
afraid to ask you then that's a really
important thing don't be afraid to ask
if you don't know
for me that's it's so inspiring to hear
that answer because
i've been in that exact same situation i
was in boardrooms as well when i was 22
years old and you sat there you think
you're looking around the room and
there's people double your age and of
course it's easy to feel like um you're
inadequate or you're an imposter in that
room but the thing that i always fell
back on was this understanding that i'm
in that room for a reason there's
something that i have that those men
that are double my age in suits that
have gray hair don't have and that's my
specialty that's the reason i'm there um
they have things i don't have i have
things they don't have and i think for
me the thing that's made me feel
comfortable in intimidating situations
whether it's dragon's den or being in
boardrooms out of my depth at a very
very young age is continually reminding
myself that i am there for a reason too
and there's something that i know
there's some in your case you know
unbelievable creativity and
understanding of the customer that has
put me there and i think what you've
realized is incredibly important you
don't have to speak on things you don't
know and as a young person in this in
these very intimidating foreign
situations like the boardroom you don't
have to pretend you know everything you
can just wait and have the confidence to
speak on the things that you know well
that you know better than everybody and
i just think that's so incredibly
important that when you are in
intimidating situations as a young
person in business or in your career
you got to know that you're there for a
reason too yeah you're bringing value to
that room too you don't have to speak on
everything but you are there for a
reason when when i read about your story
when i i've watched you over the years
and i've been close to people that
you're close to um
i could not believe the life of me when
my team told me you were 22. i like i
was like yeah sure like googled it
myself and i was like wikipedia is wrong
as well
because it doesn't make sense right and
it
as you say there are so many like
fundamental things about business and
funny money and life and finance that
must just now be like thrown at you
and um and to be honest they're thrown
at everybody right yeah um especially
when we you know we start thinking about
mortgages and stuff
in terms of money and finance what are
some of the lessons that you've you've
had to learn um
or the the advice you would give to
people that are
listening to make sure that they don't
blow all their money and get end up in
jail i don't think i'm the i'll be
honest i don't think i'm there yet
myself to give advice i'm still learning
i
i have
yeah a large amount of money for someone
my age and i have to sort of rely on
people around me to advise me with it
like i've just started investing which
has been a huge
interesting new chapter for me i hadn't
got a clue about investing but i know
it's really important i knew it it's a
key thing and i need to do it i didn't
know where to start
so i've i've been learning about that
which has been really interesting but i
know it is cliche i know everyone says
it but because you don't know these
things in school like it is so daunting
and my situation is so niche in that i
came to a large amount of money so
quickly and it was so vulnerable like i
had to sort of like get my parents on
board with it because i just you trust
all these people but it was so scary i
said it's probably the most daunting
thing really like coming out in this new
world of like i didn't have literature
them before and now i'm like dealing
with these
huge banks and they're like it's mental
it's it's i don't want it i wouldn't
even give advice because i'm still
learning and i'm not afraid to say that
i'm learning every day with it um
but yeah it is daunting it's a whole new
world
on the we talked a little bit earlier
about we kind of touched on mental
health one of the things that i was
really inspired by is you what you gave
the profits from your
one of your plt ranges to the charity
mind the mental health charity yeah why
did you do that
well it was it was shortly after
caroline flack had passed away
um
which was obviously heartbreaking and it
was a huge huge huge shock um
and
myself and prt we'd planned this huge
launch party in a big launch dinner and
we i was there getting ready for it we
cancelled it on the night because we
just found out the news and it was just
it wasn't right it just it didn't feel
right and the only way it would feel
rightly released in the collections if
we did donate
the the profits made to mind um at that
time and it was just
it was a really tricky time and i think
i'm so proud to be a part of prt in a
way that they were so on board with it
straight away and it was totally my idea
and i went and i said this is what needs
to happen and they were like yeah it
wasn't even a hesitation it wasn't like
no but we need to make money back no
they they totally understood
um
yeah and i'm blessed to work prt so
closely because they're just they were
amazing at that time was that one of the
things on your
proverbial mood board becoming the
creative director of plt did you ever
dream about that what was the and how
did that all come about you know it was
pretty little thing it's it was crazy
because i knew
when i started working with them it was
like i i had this feeling that it was
going to go
bigger than i'd anticipated
we bought out these collections and
brought out these edits and it was just
growing and growing and my growth was
was going up and
and it just wasn't slowing down and i
created such a close relationship with
plt and they
they we really understood each other and
it just grew past that point of being an
influencer because i don't really count
myself as an influencer anymore i know i
am theoretically but it's more than that
now and i am more of a business woman
and i feel like
plt
it was in it was in the works for a
while it was conversations about this
role and i never really spoke about how
it happened but there was conversations
about a role
creative director was mentioned and i
was like that's the only one i want i
don't want anything else i don't want to
be head of any other department creative
director is my role and if not then
we'll just carry on doing what we're
doing or we'll see
and um frown worked on it with uma and
they spoke and they spoke and it was
about six months in in discussion and
then fran rang me i was in my car and
she was like we've got it you're going
to be the creative director of playlist
it was a really like it was a crazy
moment i screamed on the phone i was
like oh my god like this is wild and i
was just so excited to tell everybody i
had to wait a few months i knew i was
sitting on it for a while and then i
told everyone and it literally blew up
the internet i didn't expect it to have
like the effect that it did but it was
huge
literally huge it was massive yeah i
don't know it was yeah i think it was
just no one really expected it
i think um no one saw it coming i think
they probably just thought when i said i
had a big announcement they probably
like oh it's just another collection
she's just bringing out a few more
pieces of clothing no it was when i said
i had the biggest piece of like my
biggest achievement yeah i meant it it
was my biggest achievement yet like i'm
not just an influencer anymore i'm the
creative director of pretty little thing
like that hasn't still really sunken in
yet for me and what does that mean so
the thing that brands do very well is
they they like using you know
influencers creators to kind of sell you
know we'll do a line with you we'll do
an edit yeah this is different right
yeah it's completely different talk to
me about how it's different well i have
a huge role within the business now i
have a huge voice within the business
and i think what's so amazing is that i
am the consumer i am that their their
target market really that age range i'm
i am that consumer so to have
me
in the business with my views with my
you know with my guidance like it's
really helpful to them it's a fresh pair
of eyes i think they really needed that
and i i think um because i know the
brand so well and i've worked with them
i worked with them way before love
island i've worked with plt now heading
on six years they were one of the first
businesses one of the first fashion
companies that gifted me when i had
about 11 000 followers on instagram
so i've just
we've believed in each other from the
very start so it was just such an
organic movement for me like just to in
that business and another funny story is
that
when i came out of love island i had
this day where um
all these fashion runs they came forward
and they sat down and they offered me
all these crazy deals i'm not joking
that was probably about 15 of all my
dream brands they came in and they're
like we'll offer you this we'll offer
you a car we'll offer you this amount of
money um
and plt didn't actually it was um um
zoom called me they were actually the
only one that didn't show up on the day
but they were the most important to me
because i knew
that i was like
these business meetings with all these
other brands are kind of irrelevant
because i know i want plt prt wasn't the
highest money offer that came forward
there were brands that came forward and
offered me triple what prt offered me
but because i loved plt so much and
because i believed them wholeheartedly
and i knew
that me working with them was going to
be something the way it is now i i went
with them
and it was the best thing i ever did and
what's the best was for now you've been
in that role for several months what's
your what's your what do you enjoy most
from because you've taken a big step
from being you know doing ranges with
them to now being inside the business
yeah what surprised you what have you
enjoyed well i think people wouldn't
understand that the creative director
well it wasn't just out of the blue it
came about because i have been i've
always given my input and everything
that i've done in every collection i've
bought out i've always done more than
the average influence but i think prt
saw that i think they saw hang on this
girl's actually got something to offer
she's got ideas on every shoe i have a
large input with location sets um you
know photographers
models that i use like it's i've always
never just sat back and said yeah
that'll do i'll do that i've always had
something to say
um
so it was i think they they saw that and
i think even things have changed so much
now since i've come in this role like
the collections that i'm bringing out
now like they're worked on for a year
they're not it's like i mean the one
we're bringing out next it's been
working on we've been working on now for
about seven months so it's um things are
done a lot more seriously they're not
rushed they're really thought through um
we work i don't know how much i can
speak about it but working on um a
london fashion week show which has been
in the works now again for about six
months um
there's it's
a lot of work and it's interesting as
well again i'll sit here and i'll say
i'll be honest it's a business role and
i'm learning i'm not i don't know
everything about business you know and a
lot of i got a lot of backlash when i
came forward saying i was the new
creative director people were saying
what do you know about being a creative
director you've never been to university
but it's not so much that i go in and i
talk about numbers and i talk about the
nitty-gritty of like that i'm more there
to give my perspective on how things
should be done i'm there to go into the
shoes and say i think this needs to be
changed i think this you know i'm there
to be that fresh set of eyes and to be
the consumer giving their voice
and that's sort of how it works and umar
you know the founder and ceo of pretty
little thing he himself started in that
role when he didn't know anything about
fashion other than you know you know if
he's got links with his family but that
was his first real chance and i've
worked with him as well and one of the
things he's always said to me is he
likes bringing people in that don't have
experience he i've seen i've sat in his
office for many many years and he said
we need more 16 year olds in here yeah
and what he's saying is he said is he
wants fresh eyes he wants a fresh
perspective he wants kids that
understand tick tock yes and keeping and
that's probably why they've done so well
and been so relevant you're so right
you're sorry when you go into the prt
office
it's all young girls working in there
all different kinds of girls but all
young and it's it's really interesting
because there's like two sides to the
office you've got like the tech side
which are like all the guys like working
around their computers like trying to
make sure the website doesn't crash when
they have a massive sale then you have
like the side of things where it's like
the young girls doing the tick tocks
doing the tweets doing their instagram
it's huge it's
absolutely it's like um it's like an
empire plt every time i go in that head
office i'm like blown away
and and i think if i didn't do what i
did now i'd want to work for plt in a
different way like i'd want to work in a
social media because it's an incredible
job all the girls that work there are so
lucky
on the other side of the fence i
actually have a very unique perspective
because i got to see i was in the car
with the ceo of plt
on the day when they were he was trying
so so hard to make sure you joined the
brand and yeah i've never seen him i'm
so frantic and certain and you know he
was not gonna
lose the opportunity to work with you so
yeah i've never seen him like that
actually in all the years he's a very
ambitious relentless very driven guy
that you know knows what he wants and is
willing to work to get it but that day
in that car he was like we need her he
was like we need her i can't let her go
anywhere else he must have just seen
something i don't know maybe he just he
told me
yeah you represent as you said you
represent the customer yeah
you know the customer you are the
customer i am yeah and for him it was
like the stars had aligned and there
could there wasn't another human being
on earth that was more perfect for the
brand than you and it's funny to hear
from your perspective because you felt
the same way on the other side so yeah
it matched up quite nicely i think it
matched it perfectly um
life you know life life is very
unpredictable and
everything has a cost we talked a lot
about that today even though the high
points have a cost and one of the costs
of your um
meteoric rise and your success and your
openness has was
um came out in the papers quite recently
when
someone broke into your home um
yeah one of the most unthinkable
traumatic things um from a psychological
perspective because
that is your safe place it's your happy
place it's yeah
well especially the home that we were
living in um
it was i spoke about it in a youtube
briefly really briefly because again i'm
always too scared to say too much but
it
that home for me was i've had a lot of
homes and it nothing quite was like that
place for me it was just it wasn't a
huge apartment it was just a normal
apartment um in a really nice area and
ironically i i just always felt so safe
there every time i went in and i locked
the the front door and i ran myself a
bath it was like my switch-off zone it
was like where i felt um like i could
just be that 22 year old normal girl
with a few thousand followers on
instagram like i felt like i just it was
my haven
so i think out of
what happened with the burglary i think
that's been the hardest thing because
that was snatched away from us it wasn't
there wasn't the materialistic things
that were taken it wasn't all the
possessions that were gone it wasn't the
you know them violating our space and it
was ransacked it wasn't any of that it
was the fact that i knew the second we
found out we were in a meeting in london
and we got the call and i i knew the
minute i found out that we were gonna
have to leave and i just it was that was
the most heartbreaking thing for me
because to be
forced out of your home that you loved
so much
and that you weren't ready to leave any
time soon it was like it was
heartbreaking it was awful it says a lot
about what home is it's not really a
place i guess it's a set of emotions
right 100 and what once those emotions
are tampered with and once they're
spoiled it's gone like it's not it's
just it's just bricks and mortars then
it's not
it isn't
it's not a special place anymore and i
think yeah out of everything that
happened that's been what i've been
finding hard to deal with because we um
when i drive past it and stuff it's it's
heartbreaking it's like because that's
how quickly can things change like
things can change in such a like few
hours everything had changed like i was
in a meeting about something really
exciting in london next thing you know
your house has been ransacked
everything's been taken
you need to come home right away and i
just didn't know what to expect i just
expected the worst and it was a good job
that i did because it it was bad
everything
everything gone how did tommy react
well
it was it's tricky because i'll be
honest tommy
he's different with how he spends his
money he he doesn't really buy things
he's a bit of the way he's been raised
he's quite shrewd with his he's just
he's very different
and um
he reacted differently to me i was um
much more like um
trying to sort everything out you know
insurance and making sure we're we're
okay and tommy's just like
sort of it'll be fine it'll be fine he's
very laid back it's very hard to explain
how he is but we're like polar opposites
but that's why we work but yeah i mean
it was just different and is this
you've talked about how this has changed
your desire and willingness to be
as open yeah which i find i found to be
quiet well i had no idea yeah i had no
choice and i mentioned that like on my
social media i said like i don't want to
change the way i live i don't want to
change the way i talk to you guys that's
what i love doing i love sharing
everything but if it's going to
compromise my safety i can't i can't
it's not fair like
it's really hard and i'm now trying to
work on this new balance of sharing but
not over sharing to so that i um
make me and tommy not safe anymore and
it's it's finding this new way of living
and
having close protection security now and
and moving and making sure not even my
nail tech so much as comes to my house
because i i can't have anybody knowing
where i live now it's like
even deliveroo no can't
it's not possible like it's just not
safe because
it takes one wrong person to know where
you live and i think i've it you know
what i'll i will say that
it is not a positive thing will happen
but maybe it needed to happen in order
to make me learn how i need to be now i
can't just be that
normal girl that is blase and post
everything on our socials it's not i
need to look i need to do better to
protect myself and tommy
unfortunately it's sad but it's just the
way it's got to be now and everything's
got to change
yeah
that is sad isn't it it is sad it is but
i think people understand they i see a
lot of tweets now being like because
i've posted i mean literal smidgens of
where we live now like i mean like a
cushion and everyone's like saying i'm
so gut we're not going to get a house
tour and i'd absolutely love to give a
house tour because
this house is incredible and i want to i
don't want to show it off i want to show
my followers and be like this is where
we're living now this is the new kitchen
this is the new bedroom you know like
that's me i'm an over sharer but now i'm
i'm taking videos and i'm like oh is
that too much am i showing too much
there like the newspaper's gonna find
out from right move which house that is
you know i'm i'm thinking that way now
and it's sad at 22 years old that you
have to think that way but
it's the pros and cons with this new
life that i'm living do you feel safe in
your new home yeah you do yeah we we're
really lucky in that as i said it's
taught us how we need to be now and i
actually have close protection security
now and i'm trying to get used to that
it's 24 24
7. and i don't know how long i or if
forever or whatever but i'm it's just
mad like that having to put these
precautions in place now um i don't
really wear my jewelry anymore what i
have left of it i'm i'm not wearing it
because i just it made me realize that
it just doesn't really matter people are
just so cruel and and and they are
jealous that these things it's better
off just to
i don't know i just think it changed
things for me it took that
superficialness away it just made me
realize actually these things aren't
important
your health and your happiness and your
safety safety is key i'm spending a
fortune now on security but really
there's no price on feeling safe
at all because i'd rather spend money on
security and spend it on a handbag
because what makes you feel better now
the security of course because i can go
down the street and now i'm okay i'm
safe
i don't know it's changed a lot are
there things that you miss from your old
life
old life is then as in you know
before the before all the uh paparazzi's
in the caribbean or wherever it was and
no i wouldn't say so you know i i love
my life now i'm i literally i pinch
myself every day that this is the life i
live and yeah like things like the
burglary happen and it's [ __ ] and it's
scary and i have bad days but
i'm so blessed to live this life like i
i pinch myself every day that i wake up
and i i never want to go back to my old
life that terrifies me because obviously
as i told you at the start that ordinary
life that i was living before i never
wanted that i want what i had now and
i'm working on achieving so
if you were to to leave your house and
just walk through a mall or down the
street now
what's that experience like it's
different it's i i never really talk
about that because it sounds big
headache you do get stopped but it's
it's mental and it's crazy and like it
will never feel real especially when i
go out of tommy obviously he's tall
everyone spots tommy and he has um a
really different audience to me so it's
like when walking through like a
shopping center his audience is in there
and my audience is in there so it's like
a huge amount of people and obviously
our combined following when we go out
it's heading on 10 million
people that's a lot of people
so
it's a lot of people that know who you
are and want to grab pictures and it's
amazing it's amazing and i one thing i
always say is that i never ever ever in
my whole career ever said no to a
picture because
i just i like it it's fun it's nice that
people like want to take a picture of
you like what an honor like that someone
wants to take a picture of me like that
will never feel real but is there i went
out with them
my mate liam payne from one direction
and obviously i've experienced i met him
before you know really yeah on a plane
we were flying back from um
vegas together at the same time he was
so lovely to me and tommy and like has
always stayed in contact with tommy
since it messages him and says i hope
you're well brother and i i really
didn't expect that from him yeah he's
he's a really sweet guy and uh you know
i said there i mean just underneath all
of the like
the fame and the public image and the
boy band stuff he's this really sweet
soul it's called
my i went out with him a couple of times
in manchester for the foot we did a
couple of parties together for the euros
just getting our close friends together
and um sit in a restaurant in the ivy in
manchester one person fight you know
clocks that it's limping
he's like sure
another and then they go back to their
table and tell their table then there's
another person yeah and then the dinner
is actually a meet and greet
and i'm looking at this thinking because
like i'm like no i'm not famous at all
but like i've got like dragons dennis
dropping in january and things like that
so i'm thinking i don't want that in my
[ __ ] life like yeah that is too much
for me
and how do you find how do you find
those moments where you can enjoy
yourself in public without it becoming a
molly maybe in greece
or do you just choose to go to other
places i just choose not to go out i'll
be honest and i think sometimes it has
to take francis say to me
going to traffic center on a saturday
afternoon manchester is not a smart idea
as much as i would like to um even like
the christmas markets just opened in
manchester we were going to go the other
night but we were like no it's a bad
idea like it sounds like you're being
beheaded when you say it but you just
i mean
someone come out with me and see like
it's not it's not like a normal
experience it's you have to take
security you have to
it's not like i just quit nipping out
it's a lot it sounds like you've got a
baby it sounds like you're trying to get
a baby you're not just nipping out it's
a lot to think about
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast is one of
the brands that make that transition
much much easier they are at the
forefront of british renewable ecosmart
technology and their products are really
really changing the game if you're on
youtube you can see what i'm holding in
my hand this is called the eddie right
it's the uk's number one solar powered
diverter so what is a solar diverter
it's a device for people like you and me
that means you can divert your excess
energy back into your home rather than
back into the grid which will save you
power and money it's super user friendly
and easy to install and you can control
it using the my energy app on your phone
to find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
what's it like being a a woman in
business right because there's
there's you know especially when you're
a woman that's come from
um you know built this big instagram
following and it's been on a tv show
there's so much like stigma stereotyping
and assumptions being made right but
even outside of your your role as
creative director of plt you are a
business woman you're very at the core
of it yeah you're dealing with multiple
brands across multiple deals and yeah
you've got your own companies what is it
like being a woman in business at 22.
it's it's it's hot i mean it's confusing
and it's hot it's amazing obviously but
as i said like i am learning so
it's um a little bit scary at times you
do feel a little bit like overwhelmed
and when you're in meetings and you're
you you don't want to look like you
don't know what's going on you don't
want to look vulnerable you just have to
sort of come across as as this woman
that you you do have all your [ __ ] you
all have your ducks in a row you know
what's going on and um by sort of like
pretending that i do i feel like i've
sort of
become that i i've sort of like embodied
someone that does know what's going on
because i've had to
learn it so quickly and sort of
sometimes pretend that i've now embodied
that person that i when i'm in a meeting
i can hold my own and i can sit there
and say yeah i know what's going on i
want to do this this and that
hasn't come overnight um as i said i am
so young and it's such a quick
turnaround like two years ago i was in
manchester i was in manchester and
living by myself going to the gym taking
a few pictures going to wagon mama's on
a weekend like it and now i'm in these
huge meetings with huge people
about really important subjects and it's
like
god it's it's
it's hard sometimes but i like it it's
interesting it's different every day in
my life is so different and it's a bit
of a challenge each day it's like even
today like this this this podcast i felt
honored that you even asked me to do it
because it's like i'd listen to the
people that you've done them with and
you sort of sometimes think god like
i'm not the same as them but then you
sort of realize oh wait maybe i am you
know like the likes of patricia bright
and jacqueline gold like you look up to
people like that and then suddenly
you're being asked to do the same things
as them and it's like
how has that happened like it
i don't know if it will ever feel real
things like that patricia bryce
especially is someone i've always looked
up to and i actually filmed i've been
working with patricia a few times now
and that
was really huge for me because she was
like my woman she was like my goals
yeah she was the woman on youtube and
and
i aspired to just be just like her she's
just everything i wanted to be she was
so successful so business-minded but
also so relatable and so hilarious and
i loved everything that she was about
and then she asked me to do a video with
her after love and i was oh no this is
just happening and then you try and act
cool when you try and act like
this is just the normal but it
it's not it's not and it's sometimes
okay to sit there and be like god i
cannot believe this is happening like
even today like when fam was talking to
me about doing this with you and it's
just like
these things just
i don't know they don't ever really feel
real
what do your parents think about your
life they must be looking at and
thinking what the yeah
[Music]
i think yeah i think it is crazy like
when they see me doing my pretty little
thing adverts on tv like how does that
ever feel normal and they're just
they're just really really proud they're
just my parents are divorced now um
so it's
dealing with my dad and dealing with my
mom is like two separate completely
different things but they're both so
they're both so proud of me and it's
just i don't think anyone could really
have expected this do you sometimes see
them or feel them trying to work out
what they did to cause you to like
trying to connect the dots back to like
what the like yeah in hindsight maybe
what did we do like what did you feed
her like i don't know but i don't think
that i think obviously you're a product
of your environment and how you grow up
and how you're raised is a huge part of
who you become but at the same time i
wouldn't like no disrespect to my
parents they're incredible but i don't
think anything they've done made me do
what i've done now does that make sense
everything i've done in the last two
years is down to me and down to fran
it's it's us two together like we've
done this and that my parents yeah they
raised me and they made me into a
a polite and
nice person but they
they're not responsible you get what i'm
saying like they're not i don't know how
you feel about that but you probably
don't feel like your parents are the
reason that you've been so successful or
maybe you do i don't know well it's
funny because with parents like we i
have i'm i'm the youngest of four oh are
you and we're all completely different
yeah so it would be pretty
dumb to say that there was a ton of
intention that went in from my parents
they were thinking we'll raise one
entrepreneur one yeah a lawyer
no it's just they they do their best
yeah and it's like rolling the dice yeah
and you as you said from your family
your sister's in the army
you're you know this mega star um
businesswoman and a creator so you never
really know what's gonna happen and i
you know it'll be the same someday when
i have kids and when you have kids i'm
sure it's kind of a rolling of the diet
yeah luck of the draw speaking of kids
speaking of relationships tommy yeah um
one of the things i you know when people
leave love island you kind of look at it
and you think oh these are just gimmick
relationships right yeah we think that
they're in it for the money they're not
going to last for five days and then the
minute they live love island the
relationship's over
after they've done all like the deals
and stuff together yeah and everyone's
like yeah yeah yeah with you and tommy
again you've been an anomaly yeah we
have because you're still together um
years and years and years years after
the show and from everything i've read
you have a really solid relationship
tell me about that and i guess you
didn't expect that right yeah i mean i
think as i mentioned briefly before
because i went on the show so not
expecting to find love and i just went
on for a bit of a we'll just see what
happens potentially come out with a
million followers we'll see
i came out the only person having fallen
in love me and tommy were the only
couple that year that are still together
and that were really together in the
show every other couple broke up a
couple of weeks after we were the only
people that actually found each other
properly and it's been like nearly three
years now and it's just been a whirlwind
and i think what's been so incredible is
that both our lives have changed
together at the same time and we've
grown together and experienced it all
with one another and i think
having him to lean on through all these
you know
ups and definitely lows he's been there
for me has been so amazing because it
would have been lonely doing it alone i
think like you know after me and fan
have spoken all day and then going back
to that apartment alone when you're
living this new world and navigating all
these new things that it would have been
a bit sad to not experience it with
someone
so we're really blessed to have had each
other through this whole thing and
is it is it at times quite a long
distance relationship because if he's
away fighting in or training in the u.s
yeah or you know he's with tyson doing
some training which i saw recently
is it is it a bit of a long-distance
relationship
how do you manage that we don't see each
other for weeks on end at the moment
like weeks on end
and we've become really good at the long
distance thing i don't know like i think
we're just one thing that i find so key
in our relationship and it's the most
important thing i think in any
relationship is trust we have that
complete and utter trust in one another
and i think in a relationship that is
literally all you need to survive if
you've got that trust
everything else just falls into place
because he can literally go away for
weeks on end and there's not a doubt in
my mind that if he was to be around a
load of girls it i i could sleep
peacefully at night knowing that he's
just he's for me and i'm for him and
that's that when you've got that i just
think i don't know why i'm giving a
relationship advice here but i do think
like that is the key job that is
literally the key you got trust you've
got everything yeah and relationships
require work right we had a guest on the
other day and he said something which i
actually actually spun my head a little
bit he said you know um in a
relationship there is the relationship
and there's love you only have to work
on one of them which means like you know
what i mean you the relationship is like
a a job in the sense that you've got to
like invest in it nurture it commit to
it whereas the love is going to be there
and yeah you can see it because some
people have loads of love and a crap
relationship yeah that's true so
what what work do you do with tommy on
the relationship to make sure that you
are yeah like working on it actually i
never pictured it like that i guess we
you do work in a relationship it is like
a bit of a full-time job that never ends
um
it just comes naturally i think when
you're with the right person it does
just all fall into place and i don't
know but it's it's weird with him like
we know that we're going to be together
forever and we we we're just so excited
for what the future holds for us all we
ever talk about is kids and like
marriage and i'm so
excited like i'm doing all these amazing
things but i also have that to look
forward to and we i don't see our
relationship was a job like your other
person said i i don't i just see it as a
part of my life and it's just there and
i'm so blessed that it just works so
well we never have any problems we're
really lucky obviously we're not perfect
i'm not gonna sit and say we don't oh
you like cat and dog we definitely do he
drives me crazy and i do feel like i'm a
bit of his manager sometimes the way
fran is for me i am for him it's like
passed down um fran does it for me i do
it for him he just looks after himself
um but yeah i don't know i feel like
we've just got something good going on
it really works as we look ahead then at
your future you're very ambitious you're
always asking that question what's next
what's yes what's next
you've made that you know that mood
board that planning session with fran
recently you know in the previous couple
of months as to what the next big goals
are what are they big goals and
ambitions
well
specifically i wouldn't i'd i always try
and keep things under wraps a little bit
because i've spoken to friends she said
you can tell me everything
not sure if that's true um well
in all aspects of my life i'm working on
different things um pretty little thing
and me where it's as i said 24 7. it's a
constant thing and we're working on
london fashion week is next and that i'm
not going to say too much because i do
really want to keep it mainly secret but
it's going to be huge like the biggest
thing maybe prt is maybe ever done um
so that's going to be huge we're working
on that then obviously i've got filled
by molly may which is my own fake hand
business which is growing rapidly and
when i spoke about in this podcast a lot
about learning the business side of
things that's what i'm relating it to is
my business when i go into these
meetings with these
people you know like um wholesalers that
want to take on
the product and sell it on their
websites and i'm
it's it's just interesting to learn and
i'm just looking forward to learning
more like and and as i said i'm not shy
to sit here and say that i've got so
much more to learn i i'm not like the
likes of jacqueline gold and the
patricia bricks that sit here and
they've got a few years on me and
they've learned all this stuff and they
they do come across like these strong
powerful business women and i'm i aspire
to be like that and i'm heading there
and i'd love to revisit this in a few
years when i'm there
and um can use all those big words like
net gross profit
it's really interesting with you because
i actually think you have you've clearly
demonstrated the thing that will get you
there which is that humility of like
admitting that there's a lot of things
you don't know
and i think of when it's speaking as
someone that was once a very young
entrepreneur as well at 22 years old i
don't know anything about anything
because you're right no one tells you
business stuff and net gross profit
margins that makes me feel better no but
but the most important like key
component i think in entrepreneurs is
being like there are so many things i
don't know and i'm not going to pretend
i don't because as you said one of the
things that really actually inspired me
when you said it was listen if i don't
know something i just ask it that's the
for me the mindset of someone who's
gonna in the future know a lot of [ __ ]
yeah
so yeah so tell me more about the future
then what else has got going on you've
got your brand the the tan business
you've got loads of stuff happening with
your creative director all at plt yeah
but obviously my socials i'm i'm growing
25 000 a day
on average um it's not stopping and it
it's it's strange to me like
when i came out the show i never
anticipated
the growth just it just doesn't stop
like and i could even disappear for a
few weeks then it doesn't stop and i
don't know why i think it's just people
they do find me so relatable and i'm
just
i'm excited to see with like what
happens as i grow like where is it going
to start you know and i have every every
million i hit i'm i'm like well i want
next million now it's not working
towards seven million even though when i
said i hit six million that would be
enough i was like six million a wow that
would be amazing and i'm like seven
million's next that'll be enough and
then it won't be then i'll be working
towards ten
um
that focus not become a problem when
you know now because of how big your
platform is you could pretty much go
after any goal or ambition you have with
your manager fran yeah so how like you
there's there is a
risk of spreading yourself too thin
right i guess so but
there is a still there are there are
still goals that are a little bit like
for everybody there's things that are a
little bit out of reach and i like
reaching for those things because it's
you know i
you know working with like really really
high-end fashion brands you know we've
not tapped into that yet because oh here
we go you're not well we don't know yet
but it's just interesting to think about
the different types of of brands that i
can work with you know i'm working more
on like the high street budget right now
and then you know in years to come who's
to say where that's gonna you know you
just don't know and i think with my
following growing so rapidly where is it
gonna end up we just don't know but
that's what's so exciting about it like
it's just every day is a new
is a new chapter and it sounds so cringy
but it is every day is so different well
yeah my next
my main goal has been my main goal for
the last two years i'm just desperate to
own a house i still don't own a house
yet but it's not because
i can't or i don't want to it's because
i've not found the right house yet and
um i'm so particular and picky with what
house i want um it's come it's come
close a few times to like i've got my
mortgage in principle and it's been all
really exciting and then it's no but
yeah that's my next goal is is getting
on the property ladder and maybe
building a house we don't know it's
there's loads of exciting things with
that
and i'm still trying to learn again
mortgages and all that interesting stuff
it's um stamp duty what the hell is that
and why on earth does that exist
may i ask
because it's a lot of money
um but yeah there's loads of things that
you don't realize
because i i looked at this house and i
really really liked it and was like yeah
you know the stamp dude and that's gonna
be
x hundred thousand i was like what and
then i had a builder come around and
look all the work that i want to do into
it was like yeah so that's going to be
about 900 000 just for the work you
weren't doing and i was like
this is just stupid i was like
like how but this is the thing like i'm
in a really financially um blessed
situation so how is any normal 22 year
old on a normal income ever going to get
on the property ladder i don't
understand that that's fascinating to me
how's anybody ever going to get the
property ladder with the way it's going
hmm it's wild isn't it so this is the
dart this is the actual diary of a ceo
oh wow this is the famous diary where it
all began and every guest that comes on
the podcast um when they leave they
write a question
for um the guest that's coming up oh
right so you actually won't know who's
written this question for you i guess it
wouldn't be like it wasn't gonna be
someone patrice evra it wouldn't be that
would it because
we've had a couple since then they
probably come out in
yeah exactly yeah so we've had you know
jimmy carr came out we've had some some
very big um guests recently and you'll
also be writing a question this book for
our next guest okay so the question in
the directio for you this week from our
previous guest was if you had to give
all of your money
to one organization tomorrow morning
what organization would it be and why
i mean there's so many charities like
and
so many things that come to mind it's
almost like i can't even think of
one
but one thing i didn't speak about in
this podcast is that i
am a massive um
i always give money to homeless people
always i cannot keep cash in my wallet
because i will literally just dish them
out like fun coupons to
i can't i just have to when i see
anybody on the street i give my money
away instantly because i cannot fathom
how anybody can end up in that situation
of of not having a home it literally
breaks my heart
so i'd probably i'd probably just find
someone on the street and give it all to
them well yeah i want to see wood or
give it to a homeless organization or or
something like that because
it is a hard question but yeah that's
something that i feel really passionate
about and as i said i just i have to
stop putting cash in my wallet because i
just yeah yeah
then i get out the cash point it's gone
to someone on the street which i like
doing i enjoy doing that it's
i don't know it's a really hard question
like it is i like i don't i i could you
say well because you're right right so
it has it's a really considered thing
my question's going to be like what are
you having for dinner tomorrow no yeah
no yeah i would i would
i would probably do the same as what you
did there which is like what causes what
what hurts my heart and what problem
would i like to solve if i was like
either vanishing off the earth tomorrow
or just having to donate everything and
yeah i would
people that don't have stuff yeah so i'd
probably sell all my assets and give it
to
i don't know one of these organizations
that helps people that don't have stuff
like which is pretty much what you said
there so it makes a lot of sense if you
if you could speak to molly may um from
hitchen now
based on everything you've been through
and everything you've learned what what
kind of things would you tell her about
warner about
advisor on looking back
that's a good question i think i've
without repeating myself with what i've
said before in the past i
i do wish i could tell her to slow down
a little bit
with
rushing things and even now is something
that i'm trying to work on at 22 i don't
want to get to 25 and and not have
anything to look forward to when i'm 30
because i've done everything already you
know have the best car i can drive and
have the best house i want to slow
things down and i want to work on
enjoying where i'm at because it's not
healthy to always always want more
because you've got to be grateful for
where you're at and the things you've
achieved um but fran's a really good
person that cause she grounds me like
it's a really superficial example but
i'll use it anyway
i passed my driving test a few months
ago and the only car i wanted was a
g-wagon i was like i'm getting a g-wagon
from i was like no you're not i was like
why not she's like yeah you can get a
g-wagon but what have you got forward to
look what you got got to look forward to
when you hit 25 like she was like get
something a little bit you know
underneath that and then you can look
forward to it when it comes and i was
like no no but then i thought actually
you're right i don't need to just always
go for the biggest thing like work
towards these things have things to look
forward to because i'm only 22 like i'm
so young and i've got so much to work on
and look forward to and i don't want to
rush things i would tell my younger self
slow down slow down on the filler slow
down on moving to manchester maybe when
you couldn't afford it slow down on
worrying about trying to get instagram
followers and it's just everything will
come you know in it when it's meant to
and do you think you are you feel like
you going back to one of the questions i
spoke about earlier do you feel like you
are enough now like you've achieved
enough and you've done enough and to be
to be happy you know do you feel like
you're enough oh it's a really really
good question
i honestly
i'm gonna say no because
and then it just contradicts everything
i said in this podcast if i say yes and
but but no i would say no because
if
fran or someone told me today that this
was the last day of me working and i'll
go back to manchester now and i'll sit
in my house and have babies and get
married and i won't work another day i'd
cry myself to sleep and i would not be
happy because i'm nowhere as i said i'm
nowhere near done this is just the start
so no like i'm not i am enough me i am
enough but the work i've done isn't
enough yet i've got so much more to do
will it ever be i don't know maybe not
maybe when we ever revisit this and i've
got
more followers and more money and
a better house or whatever i'll still be
saying it's not enough i probably will
be but maybe i need that maybe that's
like the recipe to making me the way i
am and making me different to the other
love islanders and the other influencers
maybe it's because i'm hungry and i
always want more
so maybe i don't need to get rid of that
maybe i'll just
stick with that mindset because it works
clearly
i completely agree and it's been
incredibly inspiring and
insightful talking to you because you
know and you're in i still can't believe
you're 22 years old because
you know at 22 years old i wasn't i
wasn't in the rooms that you're in now
and i wasn't engaged in the
conversations i hadn't built businesses
and you know the role as plt as creative
director i know how demanding that that
will be and
um how
particular and cautious um would have
been in picking you he wouldn't have
done it as a token thing no and i've
actually spoken to the team at plt i've
actually worked with them for about
seven years yeah and with through my
business and um they say that you are
heavily heavily involved you're in the
office and you are helping to build and
shape what that brand is yeah it's
remarkable that you can do all of that
and run all of your other businesses and
uh you know
keep up with your personal life as well
all at the age of 22 there's a real
mature wise head on your shoulders and
it's really fascinating to watch how
that's going to play out for you over
the coming years and i you're a force
right so i can't think of anything
getting in your way um thank you so much
thank you for your honesty thank you
you're doing a real service to the world
and being yourself and i know how i
don't i typically don't know because i
have people hold me to they don't hold
me to the same standard as they hold you
but you're doing a real service to i
think to a younger generation by being a
relatable role model one that is
incredibly real honest open and um yeah
an all-round nice person thank you
thanks for having the conversation with
me today because yeah i've been i've
watched your career and your rise with
total fascination and uh i would bet on
you for the future so you're a
formidable businesswoman in person thank
you so much thank you for having me
thank you very grateful to be on the
podcast
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast me and my team use that as an
indication of whether the episode is
good or not based on how many new
followers and subscribers we get thank
you so much
[Music]
you